is the total hospitalization rate what
you see is basically flat flat is not
great but flat may be a reaction to the
weekend Sunday Sunday discharges may be
down but we have the same question how
fast and how steady is the decline we
don't want to see flat we want to see an
increasing decline and we want to see
how fast that decline goes and how low
does the decline go right when does that
hospitalization rate get down to a truly
manageable number
when does the incoming case number get
down to a manageable number you see
again overall hospitalization rate is on
the decline again yesterday a little
less than we would like to see but
hopefully it was a Sunday anomaly
because of the weekend intubations is
down number of new cases still 1,000 new
kovat cases every day was it in
perspective down a tad from where it was
but again these weekend numbers
sometimes are a little strange number of
lives lost 337 still tragically high but
on the decline if you look at it over
the past few days not that that doesn't
he gives any solace to 337 families who
are suffering today on testing this has
been a big topic increasing testing it's
been a scramble for all the states we're
doing well on it the testing tells you
where we are right and whether the
infection rate is going up or going down
we've now tested 7500 people statewide
so that's a very significant number and
it gives us a snapshot of where we are
it's just a snapshot but snapshot
snapshot snapshot you look at the
different pictures and you have
of a movie at one point and you can
track what is happening
so it's 7500 people the percent
statewide that's positive is 14.9 when
we tested five days ago it was thirteen
point nine thirteen point nine to
fourteen point nine one point
statistically it's in the margin of
error I'd like to see the margin go the
other way but male/female they both went
up a point men are still more likely to
have the virus than women by a couple of
points whatever that bespeaks I'd care
not to speculate these are the regional
numbers in broad strokes Long Island
fourteen New York City is off a couple
of points Westchester Rockland is up a
couple of points the rest of the state
is basically flat this is the infection
rate by region people here in New York
they think New York City yes we have New
York City we also have upstate New York
North Country which is predominantly
rural or suburban and you see different
situations across this state this is not
a homogeneous state so the Mohawk Valley
2.6 percent North Country it's one point
two percent Capital District two point
one Hudson Valley ten percent but that
has Westchester and Rockland in it
central New York one point three
southern tier Finger Lakes western New
York seven point one Western New York is
the high point upstate Hudson Valley
again has Westchester Rockland we had a
significant problem in Westchester less
so in Rockland so I think that puts
skews that number but when you see one
point two percent in the North Country
two point six Mohawk Valley Capital
District you see a much different
situation than you're looking at in New
York City where you're in
twenties right so different situations
different strategy going forward we're
coordinating as a state we're
coordinating with our neighboring states
but you still have to take into
consideration the variations across the
state and that's what we're trying to
navigate by race you see the percent for
Asians has ticked up African Americans
actually down Latinos went up 10% nobody
can explain what caused that jump in
this survey and it's something we're
going to watch and we're doing more
testing in lower-income communities and
African American and Latino communities
as we discussed and the age breakdown is
fairly consistent with where it was so
that's where we are today in New York
New York City obviously high point
number of cases in the country higher
than some countries globally and upstate
New York a very different reality big
question is reopening especially for
those places with less of an issue to
begin with or places that have reduced
their problems and I get a lot of local
officials who will follow me we want to
talk about reopening and reopening
reopening know what you are doing before
you do it those are words to live by I
don't know who said it but it is a true
axiom so we want to unpause may 15th is
when the pause regulations expire
statewide
I will extend them in many parts of the
state but in some parts of the state
some regions you could make the case
that we should unpause on May 15th but
you have to be smart about it we all
have to be smart
about it as we said there is no light
switch when you flick a switch and
everybody goes back to doing what
they're doing we have to take these
circumstances into consideration we have
to learn the lessons we have to move
forward and we have to be smart because
if you are not smart you will see that
infection rate go right back to where it
was we'll be right back to where we were
58 days ago and nobody wants to do that
so what I want to say to my regional
colleagues is be smart well we want to
reopen well have you thought through
reopening and we have a couple of weeks
but start thinking through what it means
to reopen first question is do we meet
the CDC guidelines that say you reopen
when you've seen a decline in numbers
for 14 days
second we talked about on the reopening
bringing back construction and
manufacturing as the first two
industries but how do you bring them
back and what precautions are going to
be in place what precautions do you want
those businesses to Institute when they
start and part of this is on business
you know your business I don't know your
business I don't know how you do
business how do you incorporate into how
you do your business and where you do
your business this precautions that we
want to take going forward how do you do
social distancing how do you do
monitoring are you going to take the
temperature of people who walk in the
door etc and that's for government but
it's also a question for government for
business health care capacity you want
to reopen a region what is the health
care capacity in that region how many
beds will you have available if that
number goes up how many ICU beds will
you have available and are you
contemplating what's going to happen
when the flu season kicks in in
September where we could potentially now
be dealing with kovat cases on top of
flu cases you have to test for both and
possibly have hospital
city for both do we have testing in
place and is testing ready to go because
testing is one of the main monitors
right do we have a tracing system in
place we all talk about taste testing
tracing isolating that has to be in
place test people you then trace the
contacts you find the positive people
and you isolate them but you need a
tracing system and this is something
we've never done before right so that
system has to be in place when we
isolate people where do they go
isolation once you find the person who's
positive basically you can say to the
person you can go home but then you run
the risk of infecting those people in
your house or we could put you in an
isolation facility we have a hotel etc
that we can put you in for two weeks but
you have to pee you have to locate those
facilities first we have to coordinate
as a region there is no one county in a
region it's a region and these are the
regional economic development council
regions that have worked together but we
have to coordinate that region so
everybody in that region has to have the
same policy when it comes to schools
when it comes to transportation when it
comes to the testing when it comes to
tracing and that regions plan has to fit
in to our overall multi-state plan no
attractive nuisances attractive nuisance
is a legal concept where you have a
potentially dangerous situation that
actually attracts people normally
children to it we can't open an
attraction that might bring many people
from outside the region and then
overwhelm people in that region you have
a lot of pent-up demand and we have seen
this before
where when we're not coordinated we have
New York people going to Connecticut
because Connecticut has parks or
waterside access that's open we don't
want to create a situation where pee
both flood an area because they're
looking for something to do and then we
need a regional control room I call it
we have to be monitoring what happens
when we start to reopen and that entire
region has to have a control room
function where we're watching what's
happening for those friends who are more
graphic we're going to turn the valve on
reopening turn it a little bit start to
reopen and then you watch the dials what
are the dials hospitalization rate which
we know now we've been watching that
what does the antibody testing tell you
antibody testing is important because it
tells you the people who were infected
the infection rate and now resolved
because they are very bodies
what is the diagnostic testing which is
different type of testing tell you
positive and negative or what's
happening on the diagnostic testing
those dials will give you the fourth
dial which is the infection rate what's
called the RT rate the rate of
transmission so turn that valve a little
bit for a region watch those four gauges
very carefully every day see what's
happening on those gauges you can either
close the valve open the valve a little
bit more or leave the valve where it is
but when I talk about the regional
control room that's what I'm talking
about getting that data in to one
central place where everybody agrees on
the numbers and everybody agrees on what
we do the next step we have medical
centers that were built I spoke to a
President Trump about this this morning
when we were worried about the lack of
capacity in the hospital system the
federal government was good enough to
send in the Army Corps of Engineers they
did a phenomenal job in building beds
quickly we built a number of facilities
we're now talking about possibility of a
second wave of the kovat virus or Co vid
combining with the regular flu season in
September which could be problematic
again for the hospital capacity so the
facilities that were built I spoke to
the president about leaving them in
place until we get through the flu
season god forbid we need extra capacity
again I don't want to have built ask the
federal government to build capacity
then take it down and then wind up in
another problem area Javits Center we
have to think about because the Javits
Center is in the Javits Convention
Center it has 2,500 bed so it's a great
facility but it's also in the convention
center you can't reopen the Convention
Center obviously as when it's with the
hospital beds in it was just a County
Center the same issue it's also the
Westchester Convention Center so
question mark on those facilities when
we take them down or how we take them
down I'm going to speak to the county
executive and Westchester County Georgia
Lattimer about that but Javits will be
on hold for both those facilities now
until we decide but again anticipate an
issue in the future and make sure we're
ready but I want to thank again the Army
Corps of Engineers did a fantastic job
and President Trump got it done and he
got it done very quickly so those
facilities Javits you know over 1,000
people went through Javits we didn't
need the whole facility but a thousand
people is a large number of people on
Saturday as you know we expanded our
diagnostic testing criteria for
frontline workers essential workers etc
will be opening additional drive-through
testing sites for those people this week
people can't just show up at a
drive-through Center you have to call
first make an appointment
so we can handle the flow we're also
very concerned about making sure we get
testing to our essential workers and our
frontline workers we're going to be
doing a survey of New York City Fire
Department and New York City Police
Department this week
one thousand and one thousand
respectively just to find out again with
the antibody testing what is the
infection rate and why PD was out there
every day and they paid a terrible toll
the attendance rate is now good again
many were out sick but we want to know
exactly where those frontline workers
are if they have been infected we want
to make sure people are getting help and
we want to know exactly what happened
rules will also be doing 3,000 health
care workers
these are hospital staff nursing staff
doctors who are in the emergency rooms
to find out their situation and we'll be
doing 1,000 transit workers these are
the bus drivers the train operators who
keep the public transit system working
and we want to do testing to find out
how they're doing we're seeing a
tremendous demand in food banks which is
predictable in some ways but the numbers
are very very high and we need to
address it 200% increase in Westchester
100% increase in New York City 40% on
Long Island forty to sixty percent
across upstate New York so we're going
to commit 25 million dollars for
emergency funding for those food banks
I'm also asking philanthropies to help
many philanthropy said they wanted to
help and step up this is a I would say
the number one thing they can do to help
and if they are interested please let us
know and we'll supplement the state
funding with philanthropies funding we
also have an issue across upstate
we're because the markets are so roiled
some farm cooperatives are actually
dumping milk because the market can't
consume it this is just total waste to
me we have people downstate who need
food we have farmers upstate who can't
sell their product we have to put those
two things together it's just common
sense but we have to make that marriage
between product upstate and need
downstate and we're going to launch a
special initiative to do that
we're also immediately to stop this
dumping of milk going to work with
industries in our state who can use the
milk and get it to people who need it so
I want to thank these companies who will
be working with us to buy the excess
milk yogurt cheese sour cream cream
cheese and then we'll give it to the
food banks that are downstate when it
comes to reopening and I talked about
what I'm going to speak with the regions
about but I don't want to just do
reopening we have to use this moment to
reimagine and be smart and grow this is
one of those moments if you look back in
history
sometimes it takes a crisis to wake
people up and it takes a crisis to
change the body politic to actually
accept change because change is hard to
make and if you look at the instances in
the past where we've had significant
problems you'll see we were normally
smart enough to learn and to grow from
them so reimagine New York means don't
replace what was build it back better
and we've done that in the past
Chicago Fire 1871 killed 300 people but
we learned stricter fire safety laws San
Francisco earthquake 1906 the same thing
was devastating but
led to better construction and
earthquake standards Triangle Shirtwaist
Factory fire here in New York 1911
started a whole workers rights movement
and safety in the workplace Mississippi
Flood 1927 that's when the Flood Control
Act started and we woke up and started
building levees and dams etc Great
Depression FDR pivoted from that crisis
to an entire new economic structure we
went through 9/11 and we are better and
safer as a society for it Department of
Homeland Security was formed on the
federal side which was that has been the
single largest innovation in the federal
government even superstorm sandy that we
went through 2012 I was part of that it
was devastating but New York is better
fourth we have a power grid that's now
better we raised all our electric
stations we changed our infrastructure
along the waterfront we built houses
back to different codes so it's that
process that we have to go through here
what did we learn how do we change how
do we improve we talked about tell
education yeah we went through it we had
to go through it but it didn't go as
well as it could have gone we didn't
have any notice but let's learn the
lessons let's do better telemedicine
showed great potential you don't have to
go to the doctor's office you can do a
lot by telemedicine how do we learn that
public transportation we're still
learning how do we clean and disinfect a
public transportation system on a daily
basis I mean just think about this scale
of that undertaking how do you do it and
we're still trying to figure it out and
then how do you have a better public
health system because we were not ready
for this
our health system was not ready for any
public health crisis that would demand
more capacity or more coordination so
let's learn from that and let's have a
society that is more social equity you
look at the people who paid the highest
price for this crisis they were the
people who were in the least good
position to pay the poorest among us
always pay the highest price why is that
what are the lower-income communities
see this disease in higher proportions
why were the essential workers who had
to show up disproportionately
african-american Latino so his life
gonna be different yes life is going to
be different but different in this case
can mean better if we're smart about it
and when we're finished going through
this we should be tougher and smarter
and more resilient and more unified and
better than before
last point Ajay Parkinson great quote
I respect elected officials who aren't
typical politicians elected official
does not have to be a politician
politician has bad connotations to
politicians the word politician you can
be an elected official it's not a
typical politician not a go-along
get-along kind of guy you know not to
make no waves kind of guy Kentucky
governor Andy Beshear stood up said to
his senior senator in the state Mitch
McConnell that Mitch McConnell was wrong
on saying he wouldn't provide funding to
state and local governments and wrong
and saying states should go bankrupt it
is hard for a governor especially Andy
who is a relatively new governor to
stand up to a senior official and speak
truth to power that is hard takes guts
takes courage and you don't get that
from a typical politician so it warms my
heart to see an elected official who is
not a typical politician
Thank You governor questions comments I
don't know exactly where what the
president has said about using the
defense production act I know he's used
it in some situations I don't know if he
said that he'll use it for swabs or
reagents look we've said all along every
projection model showed many more people
being infected CDC model coronavirus
White House Task Force model Cornel
Wilde model Columbia model McKinsey
model they all showed a higher
projection rate they were not wrong we
changed reality we changed reality they
said the curve was going to go like this
we changed reality we shut down we
closed schools we closed everything and
the reality was the number was much much
lower which is a beautiful thing and a
good thing and a testament to the
intelligence of the people of this state
in this country so were they wrong no
you changed reality and the reality was
much more beneficial and hundreds of
thousands of people who they projected
would get infected if we did nothing it
was basically their projection were
infected yeah I have not studied those
projections so I just don't know
mayor de Blasio today said that the city
is opening up about 40 miles of streets
just wondering what's your reaction
yeah I said early on that you know you
have to be realistic about the situation
of people you have people in very dense
urban environment and will stay at home
stay at home but you can go out go for a
walk get some air etc go out for a walk
in New York City but social distance
this is almost an oxymoron right it's
very hard to walk down a sidewalk in New
York City and maintain social distancing
so I had said New York City should open
streets because remember in New York
City the traffic is wave down way way
way down I don't know the percentage but
it's like night and day you look at
pictures of New York City you see one or
two cars going so open streets I know
the and I spoke to the city council
speaker about it and the mayor and they
were we did open streets and there was a
program that was operational apparently
they have a disagreement about how it
works
I said figure it out if they can't
figure it out I'll get involved but you
need to have streets that are open you
have less traffic you need streets open
so people can walk and social social
existence you can't do that on the
sidewalk and there has to be a way to
close streets because you have no cards
you have no cars you don't need as many
streets this is a direct proportionality
you said you spoke to Donald Trump this
morning the president correct yes about
what oh I don't know he posited about
poorly run States in all cases Democrat
run and managed looking for bailout how
did you discuss first of all federal
monies coming down to the state of New
York and second well how do you feel
about him referring to that as a bailout
no I didn't discuss that with the
president look first I believe and I
said at the time
I was consistent the last bill that they
passed that only did small business help
and everybody supported small business
help should have included state and
local now when you see state and local
there's no personality to state and
local I get that
don't say state and local say what the
state and local governments fund police
fire teachers hospital workers fund
small business but also fund police fire
school teachers and hospital workers
how can you exclude them when you're
talking about priorities yes more
business is a priority so were police
fire school teachers and hospital
workers I don't know why they passed the
bill without inclusive including that at
the time and I said that I said it to my
congressional delegation everybody said
oh don't worry don't worry that'll be in
the next bill yeah but that was the
third time they said that'll be in the
next bill and pardon me for being
suspicious about Washington politicians
but don't worry don't worry when I hear
them say don't worry I worry
deep inside so they passed a small
business bill as soon as they pass it by
the way before they even pass it they
turn around and say oh and I don't want
to do state and local and forget the
police and forget the fire and forget
the schoolteachers and forget the health
care workers which is a totally
different tune than they said just two
days before when they're actually trying
to pass the bill because if they if they
had said that before they would have
never passed the bill so we are where we
are now
bail out this is not the time to be
talking about dollars and cents among
members of a commune
that are trying to be mutually
supportive and help each other because
helping each other is is the way we
actually all advance right so this is
not the time to be saying well you put
in $1 more than I did or I put in $5
more than you did right it's it's
anachronistic to the concept of
community and sharing and mutuality and
sharing benefits and burdens right I'm
wearing a mask to protect you you're
wearing a mask to protect me that kind
of sharing and mutuality is repugnant to
this they allowed you got this much I
got this much but if you want to go -
who's getting bailed out and who paid
what nobody would be bailing out in New
York State New York State has been
bailing them out every year for decades
if you want to do an analysis of who is
a giver and who is a taker we are the
number one giver the number one giver
nobody puts more money into the pot then
the state of New York
we're the number one donor state and if
you want to look at who happened to be
the donor states who are the giver
states they are the same states that
they're talking about now who were the
taker states Kentucky southeast part of
the country and by the way I understand
we're one nation you put into the pot
what you need I put in what I need you
take what you need you take what you
need
and that's the way it's always been
but if you actually want to call for an
accounting which i think is repugnant to
this time and I don't think it's
constructive and I don't think it's
healthy but if you want to call for an
accounting you're making a mistake
because you lose if we do an accounting
you lose and you happen to be 180
degrees wrong in what you're suggesting
I would say first at this moment in time
when people are working together and
people are sharing and people are
sending ventilators across the nation to
be helpful in 60,000 people are
volunteering to help New York State and
they're showing love and the shown unity
and they're showing mutuality and
community that is such a beautiful
moment right and it tends to happen
after a crisis we saw it after 9/11
people just come together we're
Americans first we're not Democrats
we're not Republicans were not East
Coast when that West Coast were not
northern we're not southern we're just
Americans that is such a beautiful
special moment there now stay in the
middle of that moment who owes what to
whom what you want to talk about money
now this is not about money it's about
working together and helping and sharing
and people are dying and it's about
grief and it's about comfort it's not
about money but if you want to make it
make it about money you're making a
mistake because you're gonna lose on a
tally sheet and it's not even going to
be close but you want to tally up who
owes what to whom go ahead it's not even
close
let's go in next casinos you'd have to
look at the industry and how they're
going to conduct their business you'd
have to do social distancing you'd have
to have monitoring it's going to be
difficult in the context of a casino but
depending on the casino not impossible
but you'd have to look at it on an
individual basis some people are
messaging me saying that they've
received mail with other people's
information including Social Security
numbers and I'm seeing this in other
parts of this data as well I know the
breach I've not heard about that at all
has anyone heard about that so there
were I think it was three dozen people
who and it was a human error it wasn't
malicious we're two pieces of paper were
stuck together and sent those people
have been contacted the ones who have
not yet will be contacted today they're
gonna receive free credit reporting and
surveillance for a year and they're
making sure to process those claims as a
priority but yes it was it was human
error it was not malicious and it's
being dealt with
I'm curious as time goes on I mean every
day we're getting message from people
who are losing their jobs because of
this does this state have the money do
we have enough money to keep paying out
unemployment as more and more and more
people become unemployed during the
pandemic no that's why the federal
government has to provide funding
because we don't have the money it
depends on many people moving forward
ask for unemployment benefits and how
long it goes on but it's in the billions
of dollars it's no doubt about that
how do they work what's the testing and
then also you were talking about
isolating certain facilities regarding
the reopening process will that be
available for nursing home operators to
send patients that are coded positive a
few other states like Connecticut and
Massachusetts have started to inchoate
only patients to take the burden off of
nursing homes so yeah we do that already
right if a nursing home has a patient
that they can't handle covert or
whatever the reason they must refer that
patient out of that facility they must
if they cannot handle if they cannot
provide an appropriate care
they must transfer that person yeah they
can transfer the person on their own or
they call the Department of Health and
Department of Health will transfer that
person Department of Health can transfer
refer that person to a co vyd only
facility which we have but it has to
start with the nursing home that is the
primary care provider saying I can't
provide
I'd care for this person for any one of
a number of reasons I don't have the
staff I don't have the PPE I don't have
the ability to quarantine them I have
too many kovat patients I'm too tired it
can be any reason if they can't provide
the care then they must transfer that
person Department of Health can put the
person in a covert only facility or
whatever facility they have that's
appropriate for that person yeah we have
had cold food facilities we have covered
only hospitals downstate is covered only
hospital we
you
nursing home because the specific
protocol on that specific ship said that
people have to come from a hospital
because when they come from a hospital
the hospital does the full workup so
when they are referred they're referred
with a full workup but yeah you can't
refer from the nursing home to the
comfort
I know but that nursing home can call
any other facility or can call the
Department of Health and the Department
of Health will take that person and find
the facility so yeah they can't refer to
the comfort I know they can't refer to
the New York Post either I mean because
the it's a ship that the federal
government was operating and the
protocol on that ship was they come from
a hospital so the ship knew what they
were dealing with on that ship was it
had to come from a hospital but who
cares about just that ship if the point
is that nursing home should have
referred that patient and should have
told the Department of Health I can't
handle these patients just just whatever
reason they want they call the
Department of Health and they say you
take Bernadette I can't handle her and
the Department of Health takes him now
when the Department of Health takes
Bernadette they no longer get paid for
Bernadette Oh money if the nursing home
is over capacitated they can't handle
their patients could a patient be
transferred transferred back to a
hospital in the hospital
[Music]
yeah I was just bouncing off the
Bernadette's point just if New York if
nursing homes were to tell the state
that they can't handle a patient or they
don't have enough PPE or for whatever
reason are they opening themselves up to
scrutiny from state regulators not at
all they're opening themselves to
scrutiny if they don't do that
if you keep a patient and you get paid
for that patient and you can't provide
adequate care for that patient then you
have a problem yeah
saying 25% by this survey 25% of New
York City population had the virus and
now has the entire much much lower
Wow the death rate is much much lower
because it changes the denominator right
this is what we talked about last week
you take the number of people who passed
away and we never knew what the
denominator was right so if you want to
know what is the death rate by
percentage of those who were infected
who passed away yeah
changes the denominator and we had it
down to 0.5% health organization said on
Friday there's currently no evidence
that people who have recovered from
carbon 19 and half antibodies are
protected from a second infection what
do you make of that
yeah well as we talked about last week
also they are you get different opinions
on whether or not you can get infected
again remember one time the conventional
thinking was once you have the
antibodies you're immune
you can't get infected so you can go
back to work etc now they're saying
we're not so sure that you're immune you
may be immune but you may not be immune
well the antibody testing does something
else for us the antibody well the
antibodies testing does two things one
what is the infection rate which it
tells you with a two week lag because
you know what percent were infected two
it tells you who can donate convalescent
plasma that it tells you the third the
theory you're referring to is well now
you are you have the antibodies you can
go back to work right we've never
deployed that and I don't know what that
was really gonna do for you anyway
because what percent you actually made
this point a couple of weeks ago what
percent are actually going to have they
had the infection and can you really
restart an economy on that small a
number and now it's saying if you
believe the World Health Organization
you can't even say for sure those people
won't get no I mean there's a theory
it'll go person by person but you'd have
to make your own calculated risk
you had it you have the antibodies my
brother Chris you had the antibodies
maybe your immune yeah maybe you're not
the I'm not going to second-guess the
Board of Elections there are a number of
I know there are a lot of election
employees employees of boards of
Elections who are nervous about
conducting elections but I'll leave it
up to the Board of Elections
[Music]
from facial coverings so if the science
does support it and had the ball is the
state indirectly responsible for the
spread by not look when you when we do
the retrospective all of these things
who could argue why didn't we do them a
long time before why were we shaking
hands spread all sorts of viruses and
diseases shaking hands widen to wear a
mask starting last year used to see
pictures of all the people in China
wearing masks right why didn't we do it
I mean it helps with the flu it helps
with a common cold that helps with
everything and we did it more
aggressively than just about any other
state we mandated as soon as people said
well if you remember when it started
everybody was ambivalent CDC or the
experts right we have a whole world of
experts all the experts were ambivalent
about a mask early on and then they said
basically a mask couldn't hurt
well I said mask couldn't hurt and it
might help so why not do it and now
they're even more emphatic that a mask
helps so I'm glad we did what we did
are you saying that nursing homes are
more interested in their profits than
taking care of their residents
no not at all those are just the facts
of the situation if they can't care for
a patient they have to transfer the
patient I thought we said no carts and
so if people are violating the
guidelines then that should be recorded
up to ESD for enforcement and if they're
not supposed to be using carts and if
they are doing it in violation of the
directive it should be reported and
there can be civil penalties and if
they're doing it in an advertisement
that is really not smart this training
camp starts in July given the
multi-phase plan that you have now is
holding an event like that I'll tell you
the end of June god I said one more guy
very students more reluctant to no I
don't think so you know when we would be
out of money when we would need the
federal help oh you're out of money now
we are now running a ten to fifteen
billion dollar deficit so we're out of
money not for your context we've paid
out as a Friday 3.1 billion dollars
unemployment already as of this past
Friday